this morning in our series a dish we're
getting a rare taste of life behind the
scenes in a royal palace carolyn robb is
her name she worked for the british
royal family for 13 years she knows lots
of stuff she's just published a
collection of recipes that celebrates
royal traditions and the classic british
pastime afternoon tea that you have to
drink with your pinky finger out i love
afternoon tea those little sandwiches
with the crust cut off i love that
roxanna siberia got to sample some of
rob's creations
at home in the english countryside
carolyn robb recreates sweet memories it
is like art isn't it
it it is yes really simple ingredients
but presentation counts for so much
inspired by the places she used to live
it's beautiful
and work
the south african chef perfected her
skills at kensington palace a residence
for generations of royalty and where she
landed her first job at age 21 right out
of culinary school you must have had a
very good job reference
i was the lucky one they were impressed
i think so yes
as part of her training rob got a crash
course in royal protocol what are some
of those protocols the first time you
see a member of the royal family each
day you curtsy to them
which can be a bit awkward if you're in
the kitchen with a potato peeler in your
hand
you just hide it behind it
exactly two years later she got the top
job at the palace
as the first female personal chef to
prince charles and princess diana and
their sons william and harry how
intimidating was it to work for the
prince and princess of wales i was
so inspired by the job i just threw
myself into it and didn't didn't stop to
think about the daunting side of it
rob was at kensington palace in 1997
when the young princes had to deal with
the untimely death of their mother there
was very little that anybody certainly
in my position could rarely do
but to know that the food was the best
it could possibly be and the fact that
the kitchen was always
a warm and happy and welcoming place
in her new book rob aims to bring the
comfort of cooking to everyone's home
with 50 recipes to celebrate the very
british tradition of afternoon tea
the ritual is marked in style every
summer at the queen's garden parties
where the monarch invites thousands of
members of the public to tea a victoria
sandwich is something that would always
be served at a garden party it's a very
simple sponge butter sugar eggs flour
some vanilla
what began in the 1840s as a
mid-afternoon slice of cake when one of
queen victoria's ladies in waiting
complained of a sinking feeling while
waiting for dinner has evolved into what
can be an elaborate feast let's try
these meringues that you've prepared the
creme fraiche with the fruit hopefully
cuts through the sweetness of the
meringue a little
you used to make these with the princes
yes they love a piping bag full of
meringue and some of it ended up on the
tray and in the oven
and some of it
with a range of sweet delights from
melting moment biscuits to cacao date
and almond nuggets
dates pack a punch they do did they
rob hopes her royal recipes do more than
just satisfy a sweet tooth i hope it's
just
all part of a bigger experience spending
time with family and friends
and enjoying some some treats something
a bit special something that you don't
have every single day
for cbs mornings roxanna seberry woodcut
england
well can you imagine nate getting that
job at the age of 21 and about that i
love that she said i didn't think about
the daunting side of it i just wanted to
go and do a good job right and being a
chef for the royal family yeah yeah you
celebrate the highs and the lows all
with food like regardless of what's
going on in the outside world inside the
family food will always be there and
you're the one serving and making it and
people got to eat i keep looking at this
picture behind nate this piece of cake
number one you can tell just looking at
the picture it's moist
and you can tell by the little orange
curls and the little powdered sugar
that's good i love watching pieces that
are about food with you because every
three seconds
i love food like you love food yes i'm a
good foodies we're big foodies can't
cook you can cook i can't cook all right
i love food we'll be right back